it is an unsustainable model to have a
hospital like ours bear the entire
burden of paying for migrant Health Care
since the first days of this
Administration we have seen a
significant deterioration in border
security are the aliens Crossing
illegally committing crimes across this
country absolutely Joe Biden are you
listening my orcas are you listening to
the shares no they are not
those are Republicans on the house
Judiciary Committee holding their first
field hearing on Biden's border crisis
while Democrats skip out dismissing it
as a stunt as officials sound the alarm
on the growing surge Texas Congressman
Troy Nails was there and he joins us now
good morning congressman
good morning Ainsley thank you for
having me well thank you so much for
coming on with us you know when you look
at these numbers they're just staggering
and the hospitals there are hurting the
residents are hurting crimes going up in
that area look at these numbers the
number of apprehensions the godaways
this is in our Southern border these are
Encounters in January so it's pretty
scary what what did you get out of this
meeting yesterday and what's your
reaction to Democrats not showing up
well it didn't surprise me when Jerry
Nadler said the Democrats were going to
boycott this because I think this is a
losing argument for them the Democrats
don't want to focus on the border they
want to focus on other things they do
not want to focus on the border because
the American people are paying attention
now they're sick and tired of it and and
so this was a wonderful 36 hours here in
Yuma Arizona meeting with border patrol
officials and obviously sitting down and
visiting that hospital of Yuma Arizona
with the CEO talking about uh the the 22
million dollars that they have uh spent
on treating these migrants and the
issues related to treating those
migrants I mean people coming in with
chronic illness chronic disease but it's
the maternity leave the number of
migrants that are coming across here
that are are pregnant having children
many of them are not receiving that
prenatal care so the NICU unit is full
there and so you got um Arizona 125 000
people women here trying to have
children and there's no room at the the
end so they may have to be transferred
and have their children in Phoenix
Arizona 170 miles away because of the
Biden border crisis shameful yeah
fascinating to me the hearing featured
three Witnesses and we heard some sound
bites from them including you a County
Supervisor the sheriff and the CEO of
the local hospital Yuma Regional Medical
Center he says the closest hospital is
three hours away so when you have a town
of a hundred thousand people who need
services in the hospital but you have
300 000 people coming across the border
that are taking up space in that
hospital he his message was very sweet
he said we have a heart for these
individuals but many of them are very
very sick and we need money is there any
solution to healthy hospitals or the
sheriff's department in that area
well I know that he's reached out to uh
this Administration and there is no
answer to their dilemma like how are
they going to recoup how are they going
to recover this these millions of
dollars because that hospital can't
afford to just be treating everybody for
free they have no there's no way to get
paid so to speak and and that's going to
hurt this entire Community here he got
our attention there's no question about
it the 14 or so of us on the Judiciary
Committee we paid attention the crowd it
was full if you look at there were a
couple hundred people inside that room
by paying attention to what we're saying
to them and what we would like to do for
them as it related to secure in our
Southern border I tell you the people
are concerned down here rightfully so it
is the federal government's
responsibility Ainsley to secure our
Southern border it's in the Constitution
Article 4 section 4 The Invasion Clause
Article 1 Section 10. I mean the states
have a right to self-defense and I think
these governors in these States along
the southern border need to start acting
appropriately and start defending their
southern border as many of them have
well it was great to see you all take
the whole committee the committee of
Republicans Democrats didn't go to them
to the people instead of staying in
Washington and talking about something
so far away so thank you for doing that
and trying to help the folks of Yuma
thanks congressman
thank you God bless God bless you I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis